A lot of the problem we are having is
actually about mental health and people
who are scared about what's happening in
the economy and people who because they
are scared are looking for simple
solutions and and are unwilling to
engage with with what we are saying. In
a way we're not really arguing about the
economy at all. often what we get back I
think is kind of an emotional response
is a pretty understandable emotional
response which is that people are scared
and people are worried um and they don't
want the situation to be what I'm saying
it is super super super frustrating when
people treat mental health problems as
if they're like a broken leg like you
[__] up you jumped off a building you
broke your leg now you have a problem
these things are to do with society if
you create society where people have
security where people can get good
quality secure work and that secure work
will be able to provide them with the
basics they need to support a family and
to support a family with dignity, then a
lot of people will be relatively happy
and and calm and relaxed. So yeah, we're
going to talk about mental health today
and how that affects the economy.